aah aah aah fwoo fwoo tuh tuh tuh tuh tuh (wtf is this??)
oh man, isn't this the best life ever?
I am having the time of my..
LIFE right now,
but if only there was a game where I could play and fidget spin at the same time!
aahh OOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO-----
MA GAH
FIDGET SPINNER SIMULATOR
Oh
There's a premium edition
In the premium edition, you get a golden fidget spinner and a golden 'vape'
I am so fucking excited
I've never been this excited for a game in my entire life.
Okay, here we go.
You know what?
I don't need this anymore
Wooow! This is gonna--
oh
ooooo
*moaning*
awww.... i'm on the hoverboard
Thank you Casey Neistat
for popularizing -OOH- this cancer
ohhhh, YES
I'm one with nAture
I've got my vape, my matching vape and my fid----can I spin it?
OOOOOOOHHHH--
shit, dawg
What a time to be alive, wait, let me try it
oohhhh that feels right
That just feels right
You should get yours too, and you can all do it together
this is-
ohh, I am dying, I am dying everyone. I'm back on my feet, okay we're fine
what is this ?
'Hold shift to accelerate'
WOOOOOOOOOOOOHOOOOO
Yes!
my-sh
Chakra is perfectly balanced right now. If I was hit by a rasengan it would cancel out itself
this is incredible what a time to be alive; 2017! everyone its almost like an inevitable pivotal war
or Nuclear war
Doesn't even matter anymore because I am playing
Fidget Spinner Simulator: Golden Edition. Thank you
Where's my fucking platinum one though to be fair can I even rip a fat vape?
Can I even rip one I don't think I can, they didn't animate it.
Fuck. It doesn't matter. I've never been this happy. What is this?
there's tears on my fidget spinner. It's Okay the salt makes it spin faster. My god
I Never thought. It was possible to be this happy let's crash into the ocean... we can't there's an invisible wall
Okay, great. Oh
Wow
This game is a game. It's a it's a game. Sky Racetrack. Let's go. Hell yeah! c:
I'm like fucking Sonic up in this bitch
That's right, woo!
going so fast
This is what the new Sonic game should have been this is way more entertaining than any
Other game I am ever playing. I am and unironically enjoying this
this is definitely fun. I am having so much fun. Shut up. You don't know my level of fun >:c
It's going so fast. I think I might actually
Take a shortcut
...
what ? you can't jump all the sudden
Yes, I did it! Perfect landing!
Every time. Woo! What the fuck is this?
Oh God , other fidget spinner. Yes, fam. Follow me
Yeah!
Woohoohoo, this is so awesome. This is hella cool
Yeah, wow okay? Alright they're fucking
If you ever want to be gang fucked by a man with-by-by a fidget spinner gang, then play this game. seriously
Okay, multiplayer. What about multiplayer. Oh, wow I am controlling
What seems to be two characters at the same time the beat and the Chorus at the same time
This game is art. This game truly is art, its a...
it's a it's a
spitting image of self-reflection
Alright. This is now a three free games. That's right next one we're going to play is a horror game
looks pretty cool
Press f to turn on the flashlight alright locked door okay?
OH I get it. It's one of these doors simulators. Oh really like the sound of that one oh
Nice alright.Alright what this is that---if you are here, then you in-game?
*pewds laugh*
you in game everybody welcome welcome if in case you didn't know you in game a
Pizza no ah
Is that the end goal of this game to find a pizza don't worry pizza. I will find you
And I will eat you
closed
lies
You're not closed
where the f*ck is this fucking pizza ? I swear to God this is barricaded. Maybe I need like an axe or something
All right, maybe like a really sharp pizza. You know what I mean, I gotta find all the pizza slices run
But you can't run in this game. Well, you can don't turn back
Does that sound open but I can't?
what is that sound?
Okay, I'm getting a little spooked out now
Got a key I think oh
Shit, I think I found the pizza guys I found the page set
Really? I beat the game great. that was cool
pff haha
what the fuck hey ah
Yes
Okay, let's play this game. I
I'm actually really curious about this one. It looks like a really fun, Lo
Little game fun Little game
Here we go. I am in Box everybody. It's super fun
Let's do challenge, okay
All right, what about this challenge?
The fuck is this oh
My God that music is incredible
fuck
Okay, this is a lot harder than I thought
Every time I say okay my okay, google thing disappeared, so fucking annoying. I did it. It wasn't that hard was
what? Did I not completed what did i do wrong,?Okay let's take a hard challenge. How about this?
ski jump
Come on fat back
There we go get speed
Nailed it nailed this challenge, not a problem
Really this is
NOT THAT FUN
what about this one, maybe this one?
Decker speed
Come on. Give me that ten points. Oh, no, I got three
Ten point ten point and go home
*bass boosted*
Ten points or go home ten fucking--God damn it
Yes, I am back. It would seem I am completely incapable of
Playing these three free games anymore
I just can't seem to enjoy my stuff
But this is the game that I purely enjoy from the bottom of my heart
I've never had more fun and excitement in a video game look at that lens flare. It looks so real
Just like in real life. Why would you be in real life when you can be inside this game?
Right? think about it
You could be hoverboarding forever never run out of battery your vape will never run
Deplete of vape juice and your fidget spinner will never stop spinning now. That's the kind of life
I want to live forever
Thank you very much for watching
this has been your host
Killer Keemstar
Yes, the best game of all time. I am now fucking a tree
this is how I choose to live my life